Was wäre, wenn wir Essen ohne Land produzieren
könnten? Mit etwas, das überall verfügbar ist?
Das klingt zwar echt verrückt, aber ja,
es geht um Essen aus Luft. Eine Firma aus
Finnland behauptet, dass sie genau das kann.
Also richtiges Essen, inklusive Proteinen,
Fetten, Ballaststoffen, Vitaminen und
Mineralien. [“Everything the Body needs.”]
Nur eben aus Luft. Aber: Kann das wirklich sein
oder verspricht die Firma da etwas zu viel? Wenn
das stimmt, könnte die Technologie dahinter eine
Lösung für die Nahrungsmittelknappheit sein. Man
könnte quasi überall und unabhängig von Klima
und Wetter Nahrung herstellen, auch im Weltall
oder in der Wüste. Wie das alles funktioniert,
wie realistisch die Anwendung wirklich ist,
und natürlich auch: wie das dann schmeckt,
darum geht es in diesem Doktor-Whatson-Video.
Klingt komisch, aber eigentlich essen wir
schon heute jeden Tag Essen aus Luft. Und zwar
in Form von Pflanzen. Die machen Luft für uns
“essbar”, indem sie mittels Photosynthese CO2,
aus der Luft, und Wasser mit Energie aus
Sonnenlicht zu Zucker verarbeiten. Andere
Nährstoffe und das Wasser werden durch die
Wurzeln aufgenommen. Man könnte also sagen:
In der Luft ist schon alles vorhanden, um
Nahrungsmittel herzustellen. Aber genau
diese Landwirtschaft kann uns ja in Zukunft
nicht mehr alle ernähren. Also müssen wir die
Spielregeln ändern: Weniger wegwerfen, neue
Pflanzensorten, effizientere Anbaumethoden.
Oder wir ändern nicht die Spielregeln, sondern
vor allem die Spieler. Was ist mit neuen,
effizienteren Organismen, die Lebensmittel für uns
“zusammenbauen”? Und genau hier kommt
eine revolutionäre Idee ins Spiel,
die unsere Landwirtschaft fast unabhängig
von Land machen könnte: Single Cell Proteins.
Die heißen so, weil sie aus einzelligen
Mikroorganismen bestehen, also Hefen, Pilzen,
Algen oder Bakterien. Jeder Mikroorganismus hat
in der Herstellung und Nutzung seine Vor- und
Nachteile. Algen brauchen relativ viel Fläche,
werden aber schon lange genutzt. Pilze können
Giftstoffe enthalten, dafür sind die Bioreaktoren
leicht zu bauen. Um SCPs herzustellen, werden die
Mikroorganismen in einem Bioreaktor gezüchtet.
Das ist eine Art Kochtopf auf niedriger Hitze,
der nach und nach die Zutaten in den Topf gibt und
selbst umrührt. Die “Zutaten” sind in diesem Fall
das Futter für die Mikroorganismen. Inwiefern Luft
dieses Futter sein kann, dazu kommen wir gleich.
Wenn die Mikroorganismen eine Weile so
herangewachsen sind, wird der Bakterien-
oder Algen-Slurry getrocknet und zu einem Pulver
verarbeitet. Heraus kommt ein Mehl, oft mit über
50 Prozent Protein, das entweder direkt
konsumiert, an Tiere verfüttert oder
weiterverarbeitet werden kann. Das riecht übrigens
je nach Mikroorganismus unterschiedlich. Algen
riechen eher fischig. Wie Bakterien-SCPs riechen
– wurde mit einer elektronischen Nase untersucht.
Für mich klingt das alles nach
Zukunftsmusik. Aber an diesen
SCPs wird schon lange geforscht. Schon im
ersten Weltkrieg wurden SCPs als Tierfutter
verwendet. Mittlerweile sind sie aber
auch als menschliche Nahrung im Gespräch.
Denn eine finnische Firma stellt diese
Single-Cell-Proteins aus Luft her! Und zwar
unter dem Namen Solein – keine Werbung. Wie immer
ist unsere Berichterstattung hier unabhängig,
wir haben nichts mit der Firma zu tun und
wie immer haben wir euch alle unsere Quellen
transparent in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt.
Auch für Solein werden Bakterien gefüttert,
aber mit dem Unterschied, dass alle
Hauptzutaten für das Futter aus der
Luft stammen. Also zum Beispiel Kohlenstoff,
der in Form von CO2 in der Luft enthalten ist.
Das läuft dann so ab: Zuerst wird Wasser
mit der Elektrolyse in Wasserstoff und
Sauerstoff getrennt. Der Bioreaktor füttert die
Bakterien dann mit winzigen Bläschen aus CO2,
Wasserstoff und Nährstoffen wie Kalzium
oder Phosphor. Das CO2 wird übrigens
mittels Direct Air Capture gewonnen –
also direkt aus der Luft gezogen. Wenn
ihr mehr dazu wissen wollt, findet
ihr hier ein Video von uns dazu!
Entsteht das Solein also wirklich
nur aus Luft und Strom, wie die Firma
selbst behauptet? Trommelwirbel: Jein. Die
Hauptinhaltsstoffe Kohlenstoff, Wasserstoff,
Sauerstoff und Stickstoff sind aus der Luft.
Aber es werden noch ungefähr 5 Prozent weitere
Nährstoffe hinzugegeben, wie Phosphor oder
Kalzium, die Pflanzen normalerweise aus dem Boden
ziehen würden. Unterm Strich lässt
sich also sagen: Das mit dem »Essen
aus Luft« ist natürlich auch gutes Marketing.
Trotzdem ist das Solein eine mega Innovation,
weil es nicht auf Ackerland angewiesen ist und –
besonders wichtig – unglaublich nachhaltig sein
soll: Das Unternehmen selbst behauptet,
dass pro Gramm Protein nur 1 Prozent der
Emissionen von Fleisch und etwa 20 Prozent der
Emissionen von pflanzlichem Protein entstehen.
Eine Lebenszyklus-Analyse der Universität
Helsinki hat das Solein mit anderen
Proteinquellen verglichen und zeigt:
Die Zahlen vom Unternehmen sind legit,
allerdings nur dann, wenn man
nicht vom finnischen Strommix,
sondern von einem optimierten Szenario mit
lokaler Wasserkraft und Wiederverwendung des
Abwassers ausgeht. Je nach Strom unterscheiden
sich die Umweltauswirkungen nämlich echt stark.
Wie nah Solein jetzt gerade schon an diesem
Szenario dran ist, das können wir aber nicht
genau sagen. Auch mit dem Basisszenario ist
Solein aber deutlich nachhaltiger als alle
tierischen Proteinquellen. Erbsenprotein schnitt
in der Studie aber im Punkt Treibhausgasemissionen
und acidifying emissions, darunter fallen
zum Beispiel Schwefeloxide, besser ab.
Auch Analysen zu SCPs im Allgemeinen klingen
vielversprechend. Auf der gleichen Fläche
können demnach zehnmal so viel Protein
und mehr als doppelt so viele Kalorien
produziert werden! Denn die Bakterien wachsen
exponentiell. Ihre Zahl verdoppelt sich in
Minuten bis Stunden. Das heißt, sie wachsen
viel, viel schneller als Pflanzen oder Tiere,
die mindestens Monate brauchen,
bis sie essbare Kalorien werden.
#Werbung
Wenn ihr vorerst beim herkömmlichen Essen bleiben
und wissen wollt, welche Nährstoffe da drin sind,
dann kann ich euch übrigens YAZIO sehr
empfehlen. Die App zerlegt euer Essen
quasi in seine Bestandteile und gibt an, wie
viel Kohlenhydrate, Fette und Proteine ihr
zu euch nehmt. Aber nicht nur das, auch welche
Mineralstoffe, Vitamine und andere Nährstoffe
darunter sind, wird euch angezeigt. Was bringt mir
das? Damit kann man zum Beispiel Kalorien zählen.
Ich selber habe mich die längste Zeit
meines Lebens als zu dick betrachtet
und darunter litt mein Selbstwertgefühl
und noch viele andere Dinge. Bis ich dann
im Januar 2021 beschlossen habe, abzunehmen.
Gemacht habe ich das mit Kalorienzählen. Ja,
das passt nicht zu jedem, aber bei
mir hat es sehr gut funktioniert,
weil es eine sehr akkurate und wissenschaftliche
Methode ist, um abzunehmen. Das passt zu mir,
aber das muss natürlich nicht zu jedem passen
und ein gesunder Lebensstil mit Sport und der
richtigen Ernährung, ist für den Erfolg mindestens
genauso wichtig, wie die richtige Menge Kalorien.
YAZIO hat mir damals erlaubt, über 16 Kilo
abzunehmen. Dafür hab ich nur angegeben,
wie viel ich wiege und wieviel ich wiegen
möchte. Daraus berechnet YAZIO dann,
wie viel Kalorien man jeden Tag zu sich nehmen
sollte. Dank der großen Datenbank könnt ihr dann
einfach alles, was ihr den Tag über esst per
Barcode einscannen oder händisch eintragen.
Ich hab mir dann auch schnell YAZIO PRO
geholt, weil es da nochmal mehr Features
gibt. Zum Beispiel Intervall-Fasten, was mir
persönlich viel geholfen hat. Was ich aber
damals nicht hatte, war ein Rabatt-Code von
Doktor Whatson über 50 Prozent für ein Jahr! Über
den Link in der Videobeschreibung bekommt ihr YAZIO PRO
für ungefähr 2€ im Monat und außerdem auch
meine persönlichen fünf Tipps zum Abnehmen.
Aber nun zurück zum Protein des Tages und
womöglich auch zur Ernährung der Zukunft.
#Werbung Ende
Heißt das, dass wir also in ein paar Jahren
alle unser Mittagessen aus Protein-Pulver-Eimern
löffeln? Nein. Die Firma dahinter stellt sich
das so vor: Solein soll in allen möglichen
Gerichten eingesetzt werden. Zum Beispiel als
Fleisch-, Ei- oder Milchalternative, in Getränken
oder als Protein-Boost in Nudeln. Pur soll es
nussig, leicht umami und buttrig schmecken, aber
sehr mild. Das bedeutet, es lässt sich in vielen
Produkten einsetzen. Und genau das ist der Plan:
Denn Solein soll Business-to-Business
an andere Firmen verkauft werden,
die es dann in ihren Produkten einsetzen.
Einen Vorgeschmack gab es in Singapur im Mai,
bei einem 5-Gänge-Tasting mit Solein in jedem
Gang. Die Gäste vom Tasting sind auf jeden Fall
beeindruckt, aber die Gerichte wurden natürlich
auch von Profi-Köchen zubereitet – und
die Gäste wurden halt auch von der Firma
eingeladen, sind also nicht soooo unabhängig. Da sollte man mich mal einladen.
Was hör ich da? Sind
das schon die ersten wütenden Kommentarschreiber,
die von ekligen Bakterien sprechen, die
im Bioreaktor Proteine herstellen? Total
unnatürlich. Ok, fair enough. Ist das alles
überhaupt gesund? Wichtige Frage. Die Firma dahinter sagt selbst,
dass keine gesundheitlichen Nachteile durch
den Konsum entstehen können. Das wollten wir
natürlich überprüfen, haben aber leider keine
unabhängige Studie gefunden, die sich konkret
mit Solein auseinandersetzt. In Studien, die
sich generell mit SCPs auseinandersetzen,
wird aber auf einen Nachteil hingewiesen: SCPs
können ungesunde Stoffe wie Toxine enthalten,
außerdem haben sie einen sehr hohen Gehalt an
Nukleinsäure, die mit Nierensteinen in Verbindung
gebracht wird. Ob und welche unerwünschten
Stoffe enthalten sind, ist aber abhängig davon,
welche Einzeller verwendet werden. Es gibt
also durchaus welche, bei denen das nicht so
ist. Außerdem können diese Stoffe häufig
durch weitere Prozesse entfernt werden.
Wenn die Firma dahinter sich darum kümmert,
gibt es also keinen Grund anzunehmen,
dass Solein ungesund ist. Im Gegenteil: Es
liefert alle essentiellen Aminosäuren und ist
zusätzlich noch mit weiteren Nährstoffen
angereichert. Es könnte also tatsächlich
helfen, den Welthunger zu bekämpfen,
insbesondere durch hochwertige Proteine.
Und auch für die Raumfahrt wäre das eine
potentiell bahnbrechende Technologie. Auf
Missionen im All brauchen Astronauten gesunde
Nahrung, die aber nicht viel wiegen darf. Darum
arbeitet die Firma an einem Mini-Bioreaktor,
der die Crew versorgen könnte. Bisher ist der
aber noch zu schwer, darum wird Stahl
durch leichtere Materialien ersetzt. In
ein paar Jahren könnte es aber soweit sein,
dann wäre der Mini-Reaktor einsatzbereit.
Und auf der Erde? Bisher gibt es das Pulver
noch nicht zu kaufen. Nur in Singapur ist
es überhaupt schon zugelassen. Und
selbst dort gibt es Solein-Produkte
bisher nur bei besonderen Aktionen, wie
dem erwähnten Tasting. Das liegt daran,
dass die Pilotanlage in Finnland nur …
ein Kilogramm Solein am Tag produziert.
Aber gerade wird an der Factory 01 gebaut,
in der im nächsten Jahr die kommerzielle
Produktion starten soll. Das heißt, wir müssen
abwarten, wie gut es mit der Skalierung läuft.
Solein kann also tatsächlich Teil einer Antwort
auf die globalen Herausforderungen sein. Es gibt
noch viel zu tun, insbesondere im Blick auf die
Skalierung und die unabhängige Forschung dazu.
Aber die Idee, dass wir in einigen Jahren
mit ein paar Löffeln Solein quasi jedes
Nahrungsmittel proteinreicher gestalten können,
das ist schon ziemlich cool. Dass wir in Zukunft
unabhängig von Klima, Wetter und Pflanzen Essen
herstellen können. Und dass ein paar Bakterien in
lebensfeindlichen Regionen Leben möglich machen
– das ist genial. Ich bin schon sehr gespannt,
wie es mit dieser Technologie weitergeht. Wenn
ihr hierzu auf dem Laufenden bleiben wollt,
dann abonniert am besten den Kanal. Wir
werden auf jeden Fall ein Update-Video dazu
machen. Bis es soweit ist, bleibt
gesund und neugierig. Euer Cedric.